hey everybody what's going on it's
Monday I was like that was enthusiastic
wasn't it I Ian the way I said I didn't
even mean to do that yeah that's way it
should sound though that's way it should
sound oh I did I did it right this time
you did it right yeah it should be up
upbeat there you go yeah that's why
sometime that's why sometimes you you
say some [__] I just laugh and I go what
kind of intro is that man buddy all down
beat oh here we go we're here well you
know yeah no upbeat man I like that one
you like yeah look at this she's [__]
she she she she can't control herself I
got night Panther
on it's some funny
[__] I go down to the dollar store I
says I'm G to get some that Irish Spring
I need some [__] soap I get there and
right above there with some That Old
Spice I'm plugging Old Spice now yeah
and I see they had all this shower soap
one of them was called bear or something
or other you know what I mean then I was
like okay it's gay all right and then
fing night Panther and I says man that's
like something [__] Toby would buy
that's my leather daddyy friend you know
so I buy the [__] put it on and sure
enough smells just like him it does yeah
yeah he's wearing that night Panther
isn't that funny smells good he came in
a told me that he's like I bought this
Old Spice and it's called night Panther
and I'm like are you [__] kidding me
is awesome
yeah that's say so Thompson night
Panther now dripping with testosterone I
know right yeah smells good though
smells good I like it it does actually
but uh anyway this flick here I
suggested this one you did yeah Jenny's
never seen it you had seen it before
long time I seen it when I was a little
kid yeah it was on television and it
scared me I remember was a little freaky
I might have been about seven or eight
or something when I saw it and I don't
think I saw the whole
thing I saw the scene where the the
where where the Giants kill the woman
and take the baby yeah that's like the
at the very beginning yeah and I
remember the scene where they strapped
the [__] little dinosaurs onto the
dudes and they start had to fight each
other with the combat animals on that
was crazy yeah it's crazy [__] this is a
French animated science fiction movie
that's not for
kids it's weird but it's very
imaginative it is I probably this is one
of the most if not the most imaginative
animated film that I've ever seen
there's some crazy [__] in here it's
happening on another planet yeah they
tell the name of it I can't remember it
egam egam egam or egam I can't remember
how they pronounce it it's all in French
it's got subtitles there's a dubbed
version too but I can't stand watching
dubb [__] yeah even though it's you know
although animated it's not quite as bad
right and um it's happening on another
on an alien planet has all kinds of
[__] weird monsters and [__] [__] on
it it's drawn psychedelic as hell you
know like it's real like like you're
high when you're watching it and the
aliens are probably I don't know maybe
about six seven stories tall compared to
human yeah they're gigant they look like
bluish kind of creatures from the Black
Lagoon looking things and they can speak
and they have weird technology that we
don't have and weird spirituality and
they keep humans as pets they got they
they have a a
multiplanetary
Empire and um you find out that they
found humans on a destroyed planet and
and they took them with them as pets and
some of them got out and became wild
they were Pharaoh living out in their in
their Wilderness which is it's a bizarre
place so
um that's kind of how the story starts
there are pet humans and wild humans and
you know little little bitt they're yeah
they're like this big size an action
figure compared to them and um I don't
knowa guess I'll leave it at that Jen
can go go into it more probably there
just bunch of weird [__] happens the the
the the one of the pets pet humans ends
up getting an education
by picking up lessons for from his owner
this girl little girl who owned him well
she's huge though and he was picking up
her lessons that she was getting
telepathically implanted into her mind
through this damn headband and when he
ran he took the headband with him and he
let all the let everybody else get
lessons from it so they got intelligent
enough to learn how to damn build
rockets and [__] and go eventually and
uh they were able to escape the planet
they made the they made the the aliens
eventually made peace with them and they
built an artificial satellite a moon
that the humans could live on for them
to live on yeah yeah that's that's and
in the end of the movie kind of happens
quickly yeah it's a t that's really my
only criticism is the end is very abrupt
this is not a long movie it's only
72 minutes so it's like an hour and 12
minutes and I feel like um it could have
been like the ending the third act could
have been expanded some because it does
kind of like and I I watched a couple
other people's reviews of it and pretty
much that's the only criticism that they
had was just kind of like oh and they're
all friends now at the end you know what
I mean it's just it is a little bit like
that there could have been a whole
another movie yeah I mean the the they
should have left it instead it to be
continued in the second movie right
because they had a good place to end it
they should have tried to make two
movies out of it yeah make it longer um
yeah I really do kind of feel because
the lore in this is like so rich that
you could really like expand out on it
and it's kind of a shame that it's like
it's just this short of a movie it must
have been from a book it was yeah um the
book came out in the 50s I want to say I
think it was 195
1957 um and the book was called called
um SS and Siri okay meaning SS are the
name of the humans on the planet that's
what it's aliens call them SS yeah which
like that said the French word m that's
man so man yeah so that's uh where that
came from but yeah so yeah it came from
the book it was directed by um a guy
named Renee laloo he was also the
co-writer on it now here's what's
interesting the other co-writer was
named Roland topor is that how you
pronounced his last name I'm not sure
but he was a big he him and um
Alejandra yski they did this whole like
surrealist art movement the Panic
movement like in the 1960s they were
trying to make surrealism like dangerous
again I guess so you know I'll you know
most people know who Y rowski is he
makes those crazy [__] movies but um
also the co-writer on this was the guy
that wrote the novel that Roman pansy's
the tenant was based on which is crazy
and also he played Renfield in verer
Herz s's Nas veratu so yeah so he's kind
of a big deal so this movie came out in
1973 fun fact it was the first animated
film that the mpa gave a PG rating to
because there's it's not um well there's
titties in it but not like it's not like
heavy metal where it's just kind of like
you know what I mean it's not that
graphic um but there is uh genocide so
there's there's that but there's also
titties yeah it's kind of a I would say
the themes of the movie or probably the
book too I haven't read the book but is
uh human rights and animal rights yeah
probably what it's about and any kind of
I guess it's it's interesting because
the the metaphors behind it are kind of
I mean they're very obvious but you
could apply them to a lot of different
things it's pretty much any kind of
anti-totalitarian um you know thing or I
took it as like yeah yeah any kind of
animal rights thing because they're
putting the humans in the in the shoes
of like somebody being kept as a pet
yeah and like so it's kind of making you
think about how we treat animals and
stuff but it could also apply
to like some humans thinking they're
Superior and treating other humans like
a lower life form yeah the aliens uh
weren't sure that humans were
intelligent because the the the wild
ones that were out there in the
wilderness they didn't seem intelligent
they were
uneducated and the ones that were pets
they had them dressed up in goofy
outfits and making them perform little
tricks and they really couldn't develop
that way either I don't even think they
could talk you know they couldn't talk
the pet
ones now there were some of the
aliens thought that maybe it was a bad
idea to try to wipe out the humans
and which it all kind of comes around
that yeah um CU some said hey you know
there were some ruins on the planet we
got these humans from there were signs
of organ organization yeah and later on
they're going like yeah and we broke
into one of their nests and they had all
the supplies that they stole from us all
arranged in there as in order of their
contents how could they have known
because the stuff wasn't opened and was
it really what it was because they could
read well no only only Tara could read
he could read yeah but later on they all
started to be able to read yeah he
taught all of them him all how to read
so he like stole their knowledge so it
was kind of it was almost there's kind
of a thing about Prometheus stealing
fire from the gods kind of [__] too so
like I said you can you can read this in
a lot of way it was a very similar theme
to that elron hubard one with the
[__] what was the name of that one
that had
uh the Elon hover [__] movie what the
the one that's all Dutch angles yeah
yeah yeah what was the name of that one
where the [__] [__] it just went right
out of my head you just blindsided me
and so I can't really remember something
Earth battle battlef battle Battlefield
Earth I think yeah Battlefield Earth
yeah in that one the uh the human main
character who looks just like [__]
David miscavage the CEO of [__]
Scientology he uh ends
up the guy who kind of owns him who's
played by [__] an alien uh he's this
alien he's played by uh
[__] who's the dude from Sarai fever
uh John trol John Travolta yeah John is
dressed up in his [__] goofy outfit
and he sticks him in this knowledge
chair and he's raised going into his
lights these Rays go Rays of light go
into his eyes and they educate him and
over time he learns to
speak the language of the of of the uh
of the aliens and then later on ends up
because he was UN civilized too all
right and he learns everything about
human technology and then they wage a
war against the aliens well they were
called the
cyclos yeah similar
story uh one captain human steals a
knowledge from the aliens and they get
technology that they need to free
themselves that's very similar story
yeah I mean the story in this is like
pretty simple um and it's you know been
done before but I think the interesting
thing about this like I said is the
animation style is kind of fascinating
it's reminds me of it's kind of like the
animation that was in um Monty Python's
Flying Circus yeah that cut that cutout
yeah kind of look diens it looks kind of
like that I think some of it was
actually done with cutouts like being
moved around and the U the voiceover is
good the music's really good yeah almost
like Proto industrial one thing I didn't
realize I was watching this one guy this
one guy had like a hip-hop Channel um
but he said yeah I'm talking about a
movie and he talked about this movie
because he said this the music in this
movie has been sampled in a [__] ton of
hip-hop records which you wouldn't think
that necessarily but he's like yeah and
he like listed all of these hip-hop
records that had sampled the music cuz
the music in this is real weird it's got
like a weird like Avant guard Jazz kind
of feel to it and then there's like all
these like weird freaky noises and like
electronic kind of noises and stuff it's
a very strange if the book came out in
the 50s with the themes of this book I
guarantee elron hover read this and
ripped it off to make Battlefield Earth
when did when did Battlefield Earth come
out the book I mean 60s I think oh did
it okay I think so he maybe he did rip
it off I'm sure he ripped off cuz I was
watching that's the same out of
Battlefield Earth yeah and um it would
not surprise me elron Hub was he'd rip
[__] off he's you know he'd rip [__] off
he wasn't that good of a writer yeah but
he had a whole I think he got the idea
from this it's possible sure um like I
said the movie didn't come out till 73
but the book came out in 57 yeah what he
loved 50 sci-fi was reading
it and well
the book that was in French so I'm not
really sure uh if there was an English
translation maybe I'm sure there was if
if it was a famous enough T have a movie
made well Planet of the Apes was in
French that's true and I read the
English version of Planet of the Apes
which is nothing like the movies no it's
completely different yeah it was still
pretty good though yeah it's good but
it's not it's not anything like the
movie but the movie is good too they
just did something different with it but
so I don't really know like how similar
this is to the book but yeah I don't
think we said but like the big alien
people yeah they're called drgs or or
trogs trogs yeah um I think the cuz we
watched it like I said in French with
English subtitles and I think they
spelled it with a d yeah um but I think
I've seen it spelled with a t also okay
but um but yeah so there's these big
they seem to have they live on this
planet which I assume is their home
planet and they don't they're very like
high-minded and philosophical and
they're real into like meditation and
stuff like they go like there's this one
great scene and I think it's even been
gift a bunch of times is where the four
of them there's four of them and they're
like sitting next to each other and then
they start doing their meditation thing
and then they like their bodies start
like all melding together and stuff and
it's like all psychedelic and [__] so
yeah so it's a little bit freaky and so
they have a thing where they I guess
literally or metaphorically
like they when they meditate they go
into these balls you know what I mean
and then the balls are like floating
around and you don't find out until
later like where the balls are actually
going yeah you find out they had that
the trogs had a one deadly weakness that
they were able to exploit [__]
had cyberx yeah they they were getting
into these damn spirit balls and landing
on these big big statues headless
statues of humans I don't know why
humans and having sex with each other
other the aliens are having sex with the
with other PE with other aliens on other
planets yeah so that was a good good
time to attack them when they were
having sex yeah virtual sex this a wild
[__] it's a wild [__] like I said this
is very imaginative and the thing about
it's not even just that stuff but it's
just when um when they're just like
walking around the planet um just like
all the crazy like creatures and pl it
seems like there's a lot of like animal
plant crossover because it seems like
there's kind of like plants on the
horizon or whatever but then it turns
out they're like alive and like yeah so
this just like the weird [__] [__]
that happens but the thing about it is
that so in English it's called Fantastic
Planet I'm not really sure why because
in French it's actually called um the
planet Sage which actually means the
wild Planet yeah um so I don't know why
they wouldn't call it that but the thing
about it is that when they're talking
about the Fantastic Planet or the Wild
Planet they don't mean the planet that
the aliens are on they mean the planet
that the that the SS eventually move to
that was like their their Eden I guess
like that's I think they I wish they
would have gone a little bit more into
that cuz like I said the ending is so
abrupt and I feel like they could have
really expanded that third act out like
to get more into you know the peace
treaty and everything like that because
it just seemed like it happened like
real quick it's a good animated sci-fi
flick it's weird it's very weird
very original the stuff that it comes up
with now it isn't as interesting as it
was pretty interesting but I I like
water ship down better as far as and
that's another one you know from around
this time um some of the stuff from like
you know Fire and Ice you know I kind of
prefer that but this was still a weird
flick it out there it was out there it
was good you don't want to see this on
acid it' probably you might you might
not want to [__] you cuz weird
disturbing [__] happens in it we haven't
really I don't want to steal the movie's
Thunder but the there's a lot of these
little brick cut scenes in between major
scenes of these weird animals eating
each other under [__] weird
circumstances and just crazy [__]
happens in it and uh the humans have the
the wild humans have uh they're kind of
like cavemen at first cavemen and they
kind of become like Pirates and then
eventually they get Hightech they're
building Rockets they have shrink rays
and [__] that they stole from the from
the aliens they went into an old
deserted alien Factory where they were
building rock rockets and they figured
out how everything figured out how
everything worked and then they uh they
found some alien technology that allowed
them to shrink things down real small to
their size and I was like man what they
ought to do is they ought to shrink all
them aliens down to their size and whip
that ass whip their ass just do that not
yeah because if you have a shrink ray I
mean it's like and then You' be like you
know that'll reverse the shrink race so
you make yourself as big as the aliens
yeah and then then can then kick then
take them on yeah I mean yeah that's
probably that yeah that's what Tomas
saying he's like why don't they why
don't they just like make the alien
smaller instead of like going through
all the trouble of like yeah maybe it
does I don't know maybe it doesn't work
like that maybe it doesn't work on
organic materials I don't really yeah
and the rockets were flying [__] and
balls actually yeah they were and you
are not the only person to have noticed
that they noticed that too a yeah like
looking well there's a lot of um this
isn't like a dirty movie or anything um
but there is a lot of phallic and
vaginal imagery in it like with the
plants and animals and stuff like that
like not super super obvious but there
is a lot of that like in the art style
but um but yeah I was going to say I
mean the opening scene of this which was
the main thing that you remembered from
you seeing it a long time ago um is
really good because at the beginning
you're not entirely sure it just looks
like a regular human woman with one tit
hanging out like holding a baby like
running and she's obviously like oh [__]
like something's chasing her so she's
just like running through what appears
to be a sort of normal looking Forest
but then she starts running up this hill
and this gigantic blue hand like comes
down and like flicks and like pushes her
like down the mountain and she keeps
trying to get up and get around it and
then like keeps flicking her down the
thing and then finally she kind of like
you know the baby kind of falls out of
her hand and then one of the hands like
picks her up and drops her and drops her
and she dies cuz it's like a long way
and then you and then they pull back and
you found out that it's these drgs
they're kids they're like they're drg
children and they're just playing yeah
like kids would play with bugs yep you
know what I mean it's like oh she's not
moving anymore we can't play with her
you know what I mean and they're just
like oh I'm just going to take this tiny
this tiny little baby yeah and it's like
one of them the girl that takes him is
named tiwa TAA tiwa I think her name
yeah she wasn't with that group though
remember they walked off leaving the
baby there and the dead Mama yeah and
Tia and her dad
walk up and she goes look look at that
you know she go it's a dead human it's a
dead home and like look at his baby he
goes yeah you should take the baby you
know you know they make good pets that
type of deal that that's how it kind of
begins turns out he grows up to be the
main character the one that yeah tear
yeah tear yeah kind of like terara or
Earth yeah cuz they end up naming the
planet like after they get their own
Planet at the end they end up naming it
after him CU this kind of happens over
his whole lifetime they do tell you that
you know the humans have like a regular
human lifespan but like the aliens the
drgs they have they live like a super
long time and they don't reproduce as
much so that's kind of another thing
where the Dr where the drgs are always
kind of saying oh these humans they're
like a pestilence because they reproduce
so much and it's like periodically they
have to do like a de de omation yeah
where they basically like go out yeah
yeah um and it looked kind of like that
was actually pretty horrific like they
go out with these little machines that
kind of look like evil roombas or
something yeah that had all these little
pipes that at the top and like it would
go through the woods and then like all
of these pellets like poison pellets
like pop out of the thing and it's just
like then it gases them and they all
just like [__] Keel over dead yeah
and then they come out with a bunch of
little ohms little humans with gas masks
and they're using them as trackers to
track down the yeah like on leashes and
stuff yeah it's pretty [__] up it's
pretty [__] up it's kind of like uh I
guess you could say that the humans are
on par with like maybe like mice would
be they're considered to be kind of like
a a you can make it a pet but it's also
a pest yeah they're yeah they're
treating them like yeah like rats or or
Vermin or bugs or something like that
mouse and rats or rabbits something like
that yeah that's exactly what they're
treating them like and it's like yeah so
people do keep them as pets so yeah like
mice or something yeah but um the funny
thing about it is that t who's the main
character that gets taken in as a baby
and this kind of like I said happens
over his whole lifetime so he eventually
he has they put a collar on on him that
she has like a thing on her wrist like a
watch and it can control the collar from
like like wirelessly so it can drag him
around like wherever she's just like
like so he doesn't run off and um I
guess it's kind of a thing that
everybody like all the drg children that
keep SS as pets they put them in like
these ridiculous looking costumes that
kind of look like old timey circus
costumes sort of like the one that the
one that he wear it's kind of like this
unitard thing and then he has like
tights and these ridiculous shoes that
have these big long like almost like
clown shoes but like not and then he's
got like this thing on his head where's
like there like this little cap and it
has these little things sticking out
with like poofs on the side and it looks
that's when he runs away like he's
wearing that so like all the wild humans
like laugh at him because he looks
ridiculous but that's kind of it and it
seems like a lot of the um a lot of the
toys and a lot of the sets and things
like that that they let the little B
baby ohms play in are like circusy
because they're making them per perform
for them so that's kind of why I got
like the whole animal rights thing it's
like you know people making you know
elephants and stuff like that like
perform in circuses and I think that
that's kind of what they're talking
about and the thing about it is that
even though
T is you know his owner quote unquote is
tiwa who's this girl who seems nice and
she loves she thinks she loves him and
she doesn't want him to get hurt like
you know that's her pet and everything
like that but she does kind of like lose
interest in him after a while like after
she gets older and like she goes off on
the meditation thing and all that other
stuff so she kind of like loses interest
and that's when he decides he's going to
escape because it turns out that she you
know the headset that she has that's
giving her all the information that she
needs like it just goes right into their
brains there's some kind of they explain
that there's some kind of glitch in te's
collar that allows him to hear the [__]
too so it also goes into his brain so
when he escapes he's he takes that with
him and so he's the one that like takes
knowledge to the Wild Ones and then they
decide they're going to and there's
actually two factions of the wild humans
there's the ones that live in the tree
and the ones that live in the bush and
um and then they and so so when Tera
first gets there they don't really
believe that he knows how to speak the
drag language and all this other kind of
stuff so there's like a lot of distrust
there and then isn't there a weird thing
too where like SS don't they like go
don't they go up this hill and like take
something from The Wizard or whatever
and then they start to glow and then
they all go off and [__] yeah yeah two
by two that was they never really did
explain they never explained what was
going on there yeah I mean I'm pretty
sure that that's what's going on but no
no that's what they were doing but I
don't understand the glowing part it was
something he was throwing down on
them yeah I yeah I was like why why
glowing I know all the women took their
clothes off and then they got got up on
this stage and they they sprinkled they
they threw something on him from above
or dripped something on them they
started glowing and then they ran out in
the woods and all the dudes chased him
and they paired up yeah and like ran off
and they didn't show him [__] or
anything like that but it's just you
know that's what was going on that's
what was going on that's how they were
uh reproducing reproducing I guess it
was I don't know
Viagra that's kind of what Viagra or
something that's what we said when we
were watching it's like oh he's ging
he's giv them all by cuz they all got it
but I was like how come only the women
had to get naked the dudes didn't get
naked to to to visually stimulate
them bring to bring that [__] on they
didn't seem to have families no they
just got pregnant yeah they didn't
really seem to yeah cuz it was they were
like humans obviously but they weren't
no they were they were feral yeah they
weren't like they didn't have like
recognizable kind of human societies
really like they were too primitive yeah
so it was that kind of whole thing but
yeah so he brought the thing there and
kind of t and eventually like over years
and years they learned how to use all
the drg technology and found all this
abandoned stuff and were able to get
their own play it like I said the only
thing that I would have liked better I
would have liked this to be longer like
I said it's only 72 minutes yeah so I
feel like they should have gone to 90
minutes and fleshed out the third act
because it just it's very abrupt almost
like they ran out of money they couldn't
complete it yeah somebody like another
reviewer I said said it kind of seemed
like that too yeah
but you know I don't know if that's the
case it should have been about 90
minutes and they would have cleared up
how the piece was made and the
construction of the damn artificial
planet that the aliens put them on that
g basically the aliens uh gave them
reparations but one of them in the
council was like I think you know when
they said we need to exterminate all the
SS or all the
humans and the other one of them on the
council says I don't know I don't think
this is going to end up being a good
idea because they weren't they were
starting to suspect that may the humans
were were intelligent right um they had
killed an alien yeah humans they mob
attack they mob they B together yeah and
they had some uh lines with hooks treble
hooks and they hooked onto him pulled
him down and killed him and it looked
like they were eating him too you know
they would the other one ran ran like a
coward ran like a [__] yeah I was like
didn't even [__] try to save the yeah
we were like we cracked up at that we're
just like yeah good luck with that by
then he like runs away they deserved it
though they were stomping on people they
saw they squish a bunch of the humans
kill the whole infestation they started
[__] and they squish squish squish
squ squish yeah like like they were bugs
yeah like they were bugs yeah and all
the human males ran up okay [__] they
[__] cuz they had been killing these
animals step on my friend they killed
this animal was kind of like a
dragon had big bat wings on it yeah and
it had an ante eater tongue it was it
was it was killing them in their hives
sucking up all the people they ended up
killing it now to the compared to the to
to an alien it was only maybe like a
size of a pelican right but to to to a
human it was huge like like a
dragon yeah so that kind of like got
them cuz they all worked together yeah
and like brought down this big huge
right flying creature so they were like
oh well I guess we can you know what I
mean this you know if we work together
we can like fight against because they
were like super tiny and when they found
a rocket Factory I thought they were
going to make rockets as weapons but
they didn't they made them as uh get the
getting the [__] out of they they they
went they went further away on that
planet and they were come they must have
been able to communicate with them
somehow yeah it didn't really detail
that yeah that's what I'm saying there's
a lot more that needed to be like yeah
somehow they were able to contact the
aliens that lived on that planet and
work out negotiate a peace with them
yeah because the thing about it was that
the implication that I got from some of
the stuff that they said because they
had you know that the drugs had their
you know Council or whatever where they
were all like have meetings and they
would argue about what they were going
to do about the M infestation and all of
that kind of stuff and I thought the
impression that or the impression that I
got was that they were in the habit of
going to other planets and like
collecting other species and bringing
them back to their planet for slaves or
whatever you know for whatever reason so
so the planet they were on that wasn't
you know they at some point in the past
they had gone to Earth yeah and taken
the remaining humans and brought them
back to egom what of Earth yeah and it
was post-apocalyptic yeah just destroyed
cities and [__] the just remains of
buildings here and there and they
weren't sure what made them they didn't
think humans made them yeah cuz they
thought humans were dummy yeah because
that's all they knew of because they
were like super tiny and that you know
they were feral and like I said they
just kind of kept him as pets and put
him in like little ridiculous ciruit
must have been Stone Age when the aliens
found
him yeah maybe so maybe it had like
reverted yeah because they don't really
I mean maybe the book says but I don't
think they even like say what year this
is supposed to be or well that lines up
with Battlefield Earth
yeah um kind of when you first meet the
humans in that story they're already
basically basically
Savages um but I think if I remember
correctly in that story yeah in that
story The the cyclos destroyed human
civilization in a couple days and then
they
reverted to being Savages then they used
them as slave labor yeah so not quite
the same idea but when but when the uh
when the humans free themselves from the
cyclos they they're on Earth and they're
going to um bombed out destroyed places
and getting old Jets bringing them back
you know rebuilding them and stuff even
though I think it was had been centuries
none of that [__] would still be usable
but it's a movie you know yeah I don't
really want you a jet can't sit there
for 200 years it'll just fall
apart yeah and that's you know I I guess
you could say the same with this but cuz
I don't know how long it had been there
either but this is alien technology so
I'm not too worried about it you know
what I mean yeah um Danny says any known
famous people in this flick no this is
no there's no people in this flick
there's no people in this flick it's
animated it's animated yeah um and I
don't know if any famous French people
did the original voiceovers um so it's
possible a lot of it's narrated yeah
French narrated a lot of lot subtitles
it's from like T's point of view he's
talking about what happened there's not
a lot of dialogue in it and that's
actually pretty good yeah it's it's very
visual it's showing you yeah what it's
about pretty cool it now it is dated all
right but it has a lot in innovative
ideas it was kind of especially I didn't
realize that the story had been written
in the 50s yeah for the 50s it's pretty
well fleshed out I'd probably put it on
par with almost approaching Dune yeah
there's a lot of details they have names
for
things and uh the drags they talked
about their they had a religion they
were real
spiritual and um they weren't able to
meditate until they reached a certain
age and they had to go that's why you
know the the girl that owned the little
main
character one day she uh got old enough
to uh BAS basically to pray they sent
her to some place it's just kind of a
weird and then they were showing
technology I don't understand what it
did it looked like it three guys sitting
on a chair and they Blended together
somehow yeah into one and then they got
I think they got rej
rejuvenated but it didn't explain it
yeah they didn't really explain like
what they were doing with all this
meditation yeah um maybe it was its own
reward but that was like definitely part
of their culture big time it's like it
really didn't seem like they had any
kind of industry or anything like that I
think they did on other planets at least
according to what they were saying in
the meetings and stuff but I think that
they like I said I think they went
around to other planets and got other
species to like work as slave labor
essentially that was the impression that
I got they had little tools that could
make things yeah they didn't need
factories kind of like kind of like Star
Trek replic yeah it was like that so
basically all they did like their most
important thing was like sitting around
meditating and being like all
psychedelic and [__] there's one scene
where uh tar they uh strip him naked and
the girls strip him naked to to give him
some clothes you know cuz the clothes he
had on were pet clothes it were
ridiculous it's like something a little
girl would dress on a [__] poodle or
something they strip him naked and
they're like oing him and [__]
giggling and [__] and these uh four or
five these things that look kind of like
snails went up on him and started
spinning spinning clothes right on him
it was kind of a cool idea yeah the
animals made him some clothes yeah they
were like these little
yeah these little kind of ball-shaped
creatures and they had like all this
kind of like red foam coming out their
mouth like they were like Silk was
flying out of them yeah so it's like
they're kind of like silk worms I guess
but yeah and then once he had some
clothes the them five girls [__]
grabbed him and ran off with him and
jumped on his dick I mean we're assuming
we're assuming that's what it looked
like they were like yeah they were like
they like the new guy and they want go
try him out he's the new guy try the new
guy out yeah that's exactly what that
was
yeah Danny said how did come across this
film I saw it on kid I saw it on
television when I was a kid yeah this is
a fairly I don't know if I'd say famous
but in in experimental animation in
certain like film circles it has a
Criterion Collection uh version and
everything like that so I kind of feel
like people that know a lot about adult
like adult animation like have heard of
it it's fairly famous but um yeah Tom
had seen it in California on television
I had heard of it I had just never got
around and like I kept seeing it I think
I kept seeing it pop up up on HBO Max or
whatever and it's just kind of like man
I really wanted to see that cuz I've
been hearing about it and you had seen
it before and you thought it was pretty
cool so I it was probably about 75 76 in
California they played it on television
and it kind of disturbed me because I
couldn't understand it yeah not really
for kids it's no it's not it's not I
mean I don't think there well I was
going to say there's nothing in it
that's super traumatic like it's not
quite as it didn't it wouldn't have
upset me I don't think as much as like
waterers Shi down did like with all the
fighting and blood and everything like
that I love that one I saw I saw that in
the theater but I'm just saying that
this
one a little kid could W I don't know
like a little kid just might think it
was cool because of like all the visuals
and stuff but there is some upsetting
stuff in it like genocide and stuff like
that but it's
not I don't know I don't know if I'd let
a kid watch it but maybe they wouldn't
understand what was going on because
it's so [__] weird it's a weird movie
it's one of the weirdest animated films
that I've SE had about 10 to watch this
movie I think probably yeah yeah
probably yeah but like I said it does
have some but there's no like it's not
like heavy metal where it's just kind of
like where it's super like drugs and sex
where it's super sexual and like lots of
drugs and stuff like I said there's
titties but they're not sexualized no
it's just the way that you would like
what they call tribal nudity right it's
Tribal nudity is basically what it is
it's not like for for pornographic
purposes no Victor says waterers ship
down was scary as [__] it was I read the
book too but yeah I remember seeing when
I was a kid and I was like holy [__]
[__] that was a great that was a great
uh it's really good yeah yeah they had
their version of the great spirit their
version of God buddy rabbit God yeah
that was a cool idea well yeah I mean
that's what if if bunny rabbits had a
religion of course their God would also
be a bunny rabbit that's true of any
animal yeah and they were finding these
different kind of warrants one of them
is these spooky [__] that were
just odd and
weird you know had a veil of Doom over
them and it's because they weren't they
weren't free remember that they were
were being fed by the farmer and being
snared so they were food yeah that was a
weird one and then the other one was the
totalitarian
Warren remember that yep where the
leader had enslaved all the females yeah
and they typ yeah they were a bunch of
national socialists basically they were
Nazi rabbits yeah yeah that was that was
a good one
yeah yeah that's a so I I feel like
there's kind of a long tradition of
these animated films for adults
yeah being these kind of like political
allegories you know what I mean CU this
one definitely is but like I said it's
broad enough that you could kind of read
it in a lot of different ways it's a
pretty general you know
anti-totalitarian thing but you like I
said a pretty like human rights animal
rights stuff like that just in the sense
that the humans are being treated as
pets or being treated as an inferior
species and so they're trying to because
of the reverse
yeah and the character is not a holier
than thou type character that was
designed to uh you know what I
mean be some Paradigm of virtue he [__]
up too I mean he he's a damn pet and
they're making him fight other humans
and one of the humans that he's fighting
is an old man dressed up as a as a damn
as AET as a pet and the old man doesn't
fight he starts [__] trying to sing
but he can't speak so he's just making
his weird singing St and uh the main
character [__] loses it and beats his
ass for that noise he's like shut the
[__] up
yeah remember before that like two of
the drgs had their pets who were female
ohms and they had their long hair tied
together making them fight each other
and making them fight each other so
they're like that cuz their hair was
like that yeah
so the humans in it including the main
characters have savagery in them and
ignorance which that that adds kind of a
element of legitimacy or realism to the
tale you know what I mean they're not
Mary Sue or anything and I feel like
they don't because even T who's the main
character and does a lot of the
narration you don't this isn't a super
character-driven piece it's more like I
said it's allegorical so I guess like
the characters aren't as important as
what they represent you know what I'm
saying so you don't really get to know
him as a character you don't really you
know what I mean he's just kind of like
a standin for an idea sort of yeah
that's kind of the feeling that I got
and like I said it's a pretty short
movie too so they didn't have time to do
like a lot of character development well
they wanted you to know that ter started
out in a place of ignorance yeah he
didn't know what was going on he was an
animal yeah it it he
didn't he didn't
get better or become kind of heroic
until he had an education he got that by
stealing it from that headband and
that's kind of where he became civilized
yeah and then he took it to everyone
else he brought to everybody kind of
free them which that's that's better
nowadays if they were to write that
story they would write him as a good guy
from the very beginning he didn't do
anything wrong nah he started off as a
Savage well he didn't know any better he
know any better right yeah he didn't
know any better right which you know
that's kind of yeah cuz he was picked up
his mom died when he was a baby and then
he just he was just raised by drugs yeah
he didn't have any human contact right
like he never he didn't see humans until
later but how interesting though that he
still had the tenacity
to leave I mean I guess he knew because
of all the information that he had got
from the headband he knew he knew that
there were wild humans out there so he
thought oh well I'm going to go be with
my own kind I guess yeah so well his
owner was losing interest in him because
she was getting older yeah so he wasn't
as interesting anymore it only matter of
time before they flushed his ass down
the toilet yeah like like the baby
alligator like you do
baby then they grow to giant size in the
sewers well she's done with him you know
what I mean it's
yeah they would just yeah you flush just
like you do the Goldfish or whatever
like that which is horrible yeah and you
would think like all the pets would be
like young people now that some of them
were old because they they aged they
aged we age at a much faster rate than
the drags did the drags did so like you
know some of the people they were have
like they were having fights well that
was like old D an old man like old man
who couldn't even speak you know he
didn't have any education or anything
yeah but they just kept him as a pet and
he's like hey we could fight other ones
like you know what I mean yeah but he
wasn't a fighter he was like skinny
you know just a skinny old man they were
just putting random pets together and
trying to get him to fight yeah cuz they
kids doing it yeah that's what I mean
it's just like the same way that kids
would just thoughtlessly try to get
Turtles to fight right something like
that you know it's it's it's kind of the
same mentality is like kids that like
burn ants you know with the with the
magnifying glass [__] like that used to
set them on fire yeah my brother did
that whole M my brother did that try to
wipe out the whole Mount put gasoline on
it set on fire I never did that
yeah but my brother used to burn him
with the magnifying glass though yeah
used to burn up the try to burn up the
ant mounds which is kind of [__] up I
mean I know they're n you're going to
use you're going to use
them you're going to use poison anyway
true but you know just they were in the
backyard you know
yeah yeah you fall in there and they all
start stinging you yeah red ants and
[__] yeah all right so um you ready to
wrap it up I guess all right
so we're going to go have something to
eat and uh and then so Wednesday night's
show is be a good one yeah this is gonna
we're finally going to talk about
Jeffrey Epstein yeah um because tomson
wanted to do a show about that you guys
asked about it yeah and like I said it
won in the poll last week but Tom wasn't
here so I'm I pushed it back to this
week so we're going to do that so uh we
actually I watched the Netflix docu
series about him but they put up one
about what's her face too Gan Maxwell
Gan Maxwell they put up one about about
her so if you want to if we want to
watch both of those we can watch one
tonight and one tomorrow night we'll see
how that goes but yeah so that should be
a fun show it'll probably go on for
hours and hours I'm sure there's a lot
it's a lot of information you know what
I mean it's kind of hard and there's a
lot of information about it out there so
it's kind of hard to distill it and I'm
I'm going to be skeptical of the
information we're going to be getting
through these uh [__] the the these
[__] mainstream sources because you
know they censored that [__] you know
they're going to because they got to
protect their own in there yeah just
what they want us to know right but yeah
so that'll be the show on Wednesday and
that should be a lot of fun but yeah so
uh thanks for dropping by this evening
like I said this movie is if you like
animated films like for adults and stuff
like that it's came out in the 70s and
it's pretty [__] weird one of the
weirdest things I've ever seen very
trippy um I think we watched it on HBO
Max it might have been Amazon Prime but
I'm pretty sure it was HBO Max but
that's where I saw it so maybe you can
find it streaming elsewhere if you want
to see it but yeah uh it's pretty good
and I recommend it so we will see you
guys again on Wednesday night thank you
for dropping by remember to like and all
of that kind of stuff and we'll see you
again on Wednesday good